when you seek to have an AI teach
another AI that's not going to happen
and what we know already very clearly is
that when you train an AI on anything
that an AI has done it quickly devolves
into nonsense the images become garbled
and the text becomes useless and that's
why they have gone to Great Lengths to
make sure that nothing in the corpuses
Corpi that they're teaching in AI is
something that came from an AI and why
they had to draw a line on the internet
a couple years ago and say I don't know
anything that happened on the internet
after that date because a lot of stuff
on the internet is going to be written
by Ai and that will corrode the whole
thing